ce dimanche 9 avril le sky rugby joué sa
survie dans le championnat de division
honneur à domicile face à ministère
finance paris un match à enjeu qui n'a
pas tétanisé le promu dès les premières
minutes de la rencontre les saint
quentinois mettre du rythme et remporte
la première période 17 à 7
avec deux essais inscrits à la comptait
c'était de se faire plaisir malgré la
pression du maintien
maintenant on voit que il ya un vrai
objectif parce que l'intensité est
vraiment présente au retour des
vestiaires le sky rugby continue sur sa
lancée les bleus réalisent un 100% au
pied en seconde période grâce à jude law
berès la faille pour l'emporter 29 à 14
au coup de sifflet final
ce collectif l'équipe l'équipe va bien
marcher devant derrière c'est bien
connecté
les lancements de jeu était propre on a
fait exactement ce qu'on a voulu faire
avec cette victoire les saint quentinois
sont assurés de terminer à la huitième
place sur dix équipes engagées avec
quatre points d'avancé sur nantes limer
le premier relégable le staff se
projette déjà sur la saison prochaine
il faut pas rajouter une seule chose il
faut toujours ajouté plein de petites
choses pour que ça se passe bien
la fois être meilleur a physiquement
meilleurs joueurs qui viennent un peu
plus un peu plus chanceux sur blessure
parce qu'on a bien chargé cette année en
blessure donc donc ça arrive mais alors
où changera peut-être besoin de moi de
malchance là dessus et après c'est
toujours progresser c'est à dire que là
au match aller on a fait on a fait trois
victoires et au match retour on a fait 3
victoires + 1 nul donc ces lieux le sky
rugby clôturera sa saison ce dimanche 15
avril contre vincennes à domicile en
match en retard
l'occasion de préparer déjà la saison
2018 2019
[Applaudissements]